Harlem New York July 5th
members of the New York Trenton and
Newark chapter of the new Black Panther
Party march along Frederick Douglass
Boulevard to 125th Street in New York
City they have come to celebrate a
festival that call the fourth of July
it's an ironic and accusatory title
highlighting the fact that American
independence in 1776 did nothing for
enslaved blacks in fact the constitution
when ratified measured all slaves as
only three-fifths of a person Frederick
Douglass argued that July 4th had a
different meaning for African Americans
than for whites at that day July 4th
1776 the vast majority of black people
in North America were enslaved and then
for the remaining another 90 years they
found themselves also enslaved
shaaka Shakur's the leader of the Harlem
chapter of the new Black Panther Party
even in the midst of Barack Obama's
historic run for the White House the new
Black Panther Party rejects the idea
that politics will provide any real
change in early 21st century we see
considerable expansion of black economic
political prowess and the visibility and
a diversity of by people in popular
culture and the proliferation of black
people in various aslong as a power
speak to the progress that clearly has
been made and that doesn't mean that
there aren't still vestiges of white
supremacy and for those reasons there
are vestiges of black nationalist
sentiment the Panthers are calling on
the gathering crowd to show their
disdain for the u.s. system by walking
on the flag being over the white
represents the white man the devil the
devil who brought you over there watch
how many people are scared to step on
that right you might on you for for
honey is we're always in a war for the
hearts and minds of black people African
people because we all know July 4th just
passed by and we want people to
understand especially black people to
understand that we have no reason
celebrating the independence that we
don't possess if we were looking around
our neighborhoods
we live in the worst conditions and this
is supposed to be the best country so
how can we possibly begin to talk about
independence when we're not even
independent from European colonialism on
any level be it mental physical or
spiritual
the new Black Panther Party burns the
flag to show their hatred for the US
government they are calling for a new
system of government for and by blacks
Whitey's independence day